oh
god
this is bad
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be reviewing
pamela reef and her wellness app pam app
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor nectar so you guys know i am
really picky about my bedtime routine
i'm literally like the princess and the
pee where if one teeny tiny little
detail of my night is off i risk being
up all night long so i was really
excited and kind of anxious about trying
my new nectar mattress and i gotta tell
you i totally see what all the fuss is
about this is an award-winning 14-inch
gel memory foam mattress with three
supportive layers to help prevent
sinking
contour to your unique body and keep you
cool and i run really hot so a cool
mattress is really key for me i also
love that the foam they use is serta
pure us certified so it's free of ozone
depleters honestly i've always said that
your mattress choice is so important
considering that you spend half of your
life on it so it is worth investing in
something that you love so if you're in
the market for a new mattress nectar
actually has a 365 night trial a forever
warranty and free shipping and returns
so for more information on nectar check
out my link in the description now as
always you can pause the screen or look
at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating i
will be talking calories and macros so
feel free to skip that portion if it is
not supportive to your journey and of
course don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and ring that little bell so
that you never miss out on an episode
okay friends let's begin with a little
background on pamela reef so pamela is
germany's leading fitness and food
influencer
you may know her from her popular killer
home workout videos which certainly came
in clutch mid pandemic but unless you
are an avid pam stan
you may not know that she's also a major
foodie she's even in the process of
developing a new cookbook and it's
recently launched the pam app where she
shares workout routines nutrition and
wellness blog posts recipes and meal
plans since the launch of the app i have
been overwhelmed with dms and comments
you know your dm's will be blowing up
asking me to review it and also flagging
some of her messaging around her diet so
i downloaded the app to give you my
honest thoughts all right so let's start
with a quick overview of what pam's app
has to offer so for three dollars a
month or 30 a year the pam app offers
fitness videos healthy recipes and
wellness tips the app also includes a
shopping list feature exercise scheduler
and for an additional fee you can also
add the recipes from a previously
published cookbook the recipes and
information provided through the app
centers around quick and easy homemade
meals that take into consideration
environmental sustainability and
affordability which are attributes that
we love to see and at face value this
all sounds great but obviously i had to
dive a little bit deeper and it wasn't
long before i hit a treasure trove of
diet culture rhetoric in the app store
description and i hadn't even downloaded
it yet so pamla says that her recipes
replace the
bad ingredients in classic recipes her
recipes do not include a lot of fat or
sugar because it's not aligned with a
fit lifestyle and she also says that her
job is to have a flat tummy and toned
thighs which isn't even that hard i'm
sorry that isn't even that hard now in
all fairness it's quite possible some of
the questionable wording used may be
just attributed to translation
challenges but i do believe that
language is powerful and important here
especially when talking about wellness
and health so if you're going to launch
your program in english-speaking
countries hire an english-speaking
copywriter to just check it over so that
you don't end up with that
yikes
not good it's quite clear to me just
from a quick glimpse at this description
that pam has a tendency to subscribe to
a very black and white dichotomous view
of food and interestingly
this seems at odds with her own
suggestion that she eats intuitively
herself i also have to say that i feel a
little cheated after seeing language
like this considering that her food
instagram account
looks so freaking good but it's really
disappointing that those delicious
looking snacks and desserts and meals
are needing to be accompanied by this
kind of restrictive and problematic
rhetoric i also just need to flag that
pam's suggestion that it's not that hard
to have a body like hers is not only
misleading and disheartening but it's
also factually wrong pam is a 24 year
old fitness influencer her body is
likely the result of an extremely active
lifestyle a restrictive diet and lucky
genetics not to mention that most women
need to get down below 20 of body fat to
see ab definition and most women also
need over 20 body fat to maintain normal
menstruation and hormone function so
please do not be discouraged if you are
putting in the work and you don't look
like pam as a result it might not even
be healthy for you but anyways moving on
let's take a look at the recipes in the
pam app so first off i want to talk
about the good all the nutrition details
that i mentioned in this video are based
off of the stats listed on the app but
what i love is that these numbers are
located on a separate tab from the
recipes themselves and the app
encourages subscribers to ignore this
information if it's not supportive to
their health this to me is probably one
of the best and most thoughtful
attributes of the pan map itself
but don't get too excited here folks
because there's a lot not to love as
well huge disappointment so everything
on the pan map is dairy free fish free
and wheat free and there's limited meat
offerings and soy offerings and that is
totally cool and also it does make sense
since pamela herself adheres to these
dietary restrictions
largely apparently due to environmental
and animal welfare concerns
on her blog she does suggest that she
tries not to impose these restrictions
on others and instead encourages her
fans to choose more sustainable options
if they are going to eat meat and
ultimately i do appreciate that
statement so now i want to touch on what
pam allegedly eats in a day as per her
app and also discuss some of those diet
restrictions
that i just mentioned first of all pam
says she does not consume soy products
due to her belief that they can mess up
our hormone balance because of their
isoflavone content so this is a
tremendously
complicated topic so
i'm gonna try to keep it light but the
isoflavones found in soy are selective
estrogen reception modulators which
means that sometimes they can have
either a weak estrogenic effect or
sometimes they can actually have an
anti-estrogenic effect confusing i know
i would need a whole video to go through
this but in short a meta-analysis found
that soy consumption had no impact on
thyroid health nor does consuming normal
amounts of it cause male feminization or
increase the risk of breast cancer
in fact one meta-analysis even suggested
that it might reduce that risk but like
i said this is super complicated so i'm
gonna link to a blog post below um that
i wrote on this topic but i'll also just
say that avoiding soy in addition to all
other animal products and wheat
definitely will make it more challenging
to get in a nice variety of protein and
iron sources in her day now in addition
to soy another big pam no-no is wheat
which i just mentioned which she states
is a personal preference but then also
she reveals that she believes wheat is
empty carbohydrates along with her other
arch nemesis
sugar so as a result most of pam's
recipes feature gluten-free grains or
pseudograins and she uses coconut
blossom sugar to sweeten my take is that
sugar is sugar is sugar yes something
like coconut sugar has a marginally
lower glycemic index with researchers at
the university of sydney reporting a gi
value of 54 which is only slightly
better than white sugar's rating of 65.
it's also more than 10 times the price
but ultimately both have 15 calories and
4 grams of carbs per teaspoon
and both should be enjoyed in moderation
so i say choose a sweetener that you
actually enjoy and move on with your
life but let's take a look at her day so
for breakfast most days pam has some
sort of oatmeal bowl combining some
whole grains fruits and nuts one of her
favorites is a sweet scrambled egg
recipe with banana and coconut which i
know sounds kind of strange but i
actually have made sweet eggs before
myself
and i personally love the technique it's
not unlike my famous whipped protest
recipe that everyone is obsessed with
and in pamela's case i love that we have
some protein and fat in the eggs
carbs the banana and fiber and fat in
the coconut it's also a hearty portion
at over 500 calories so i would bet that
this would keep someone pretty satisfied
now baked oatmeal is another breakfast
staple of pams and one really delicious
example is her choco peanut butter lava
porridge oh my gosh it looks so good so
this one has fiber rich carbs from the
whole grain oats protein the healthy
fats from the peanut butter
carbs from the banana super delicious
and of course some chocolate in there
for good measure love it now it is worth
pointing out though that when we
calculated the macros on this it clocked
in at significantly less protein than
what the app actually listed so i'm not
sure but there may be some
inconsistencies in that or maybe the
ingredients that she uses are very
different than what we find in north
america but regardless it does have the
hunger crushing combo and it looks super
tasty so yeah i'm definitely giving this
one a try now i also noticed that she
often uses sweet potato as a non-bread
alternative to whole grain toast but
acknowledges that this is not a
substitute but rather a good alternative
so i do like this sentiment it is
refreshing to see since a lot of
influencers insinuate that there's
something inherently bad about having
like a piece of actual real bread but i
do think this really does come down to
intention and again the language we use
diet culture would say sweet potatoes
are toast because eating real bread is
bad for you but a more morally neutral
way of looking at this would be to say
hey you know
it's not bread it is in fact a sweet
potato made
into the shape of toast and i can enjoy
both of them or
one more than the other when i'm craving
like a different nutrition and sensory
experience both are delicious and both
are nutritious options to keep in the
rotation so again
language and intention are really really
key
to help keep us out of scarcity
mentality with these kind of wellness
food swaps now moving on to lunch pam
often has like a grain-based bowl or a
salad like this whole grain spelt pasta
with a creamy veggie sauce made with
carrots potatoes and water she then tops
it off with tomatoes olives and turkey
bacon for a little protein and fat again
another beautifully balanced meal with a
solid 20 grams of protein and i really
like using meat as more of like a
garnish than the main dish which i think
is particularly beneficial when we're
using like a higher sodium processed
meat like bacon i generally do try to
think about serving meat this way aka
what i call conda meat
as for the spelt pasta it does have
slightly more protein and fiber than
regular whole wheat pasta and it is only
a little bit more expensive per 100
grams so as long as pam enjoys the swap
i think it does make sense now when we
get to dinner we notice that pam usually
tends to keep her evening meals pretty
light and low carb so for example her
peanut butter chicken with veggies
sounds delicious and it does pack a
solid amount of protein healthy fats and
some fiber in the veg but we could
definitely add in like a side of rice
sweet potatoes or another whole grain
just to really help bump up the
satisfaction factor another dinner
favorite is her shakshuka which has a
solid 26 grams of protein from eggs
simmered in a tomato pasada sauce but
again we would definitely want to see
some carb action going on so
i would probably do like a nice hearty
sourdough bread or some gluten-free pita
just to stop up that delicious yummy
sauce finally let's talk dessert so pam
usually ends the day with something
sweet often it's like a small date nut
based ball some avocado chocolate mousse
or her healthified carrot cake now while
i am all for more nutrient dense takes
on dessert and i myself make chocolate
avocado mousse for my toddler all the
time i was kind of annoyed with pam's
disclaimer on the recipe that
it does not contain a trace of regular
chocolate and that she will even leave
out the dates from time to time to enjoy
a 100
clean fitness appropriate dessert yeah
i don't know who needs to hear this but
dates can absolutely be part of a
fitness influencers diet anyways she
also suggests that the carrot cake i
mentioned could be turned into a cheat
depending on your sugar preference so
yeah that kind of put a sour taste in my
mouth and really made me lose my
appetite for said desserts but anyways
let's talk about the stats here
now according to an instagram q a i read
from pam
pam says she no longer counts calories
as she is back to intuitive eating but
she thinks that she eats between 1800
calories and 2 200 calories per day i
would say even if that were true it
would very likely not even be enough for
a woman her side doing the activity that
she does every day when i actually
calculated her weekly sample menu her
intake ranged from about 1350 to 1550
calories aka just not enough her protein
came in at 60 of her daily calories
carbs at 38
and fat at 44
which definitely puts her on the low end
for protein and carbs for someone in the
fitness community
i would definitely be worried about
optimal pre-workout fuel and
post-workout recovery on a diet as
restrictive as this so let's talk about
a few things that i would suggest we
focus on to help her better meet her
daily needs
now while i am generally really happy to
see pamela eating solid balanced daytime
meals with healthy portions i do think
we could really bump up that dinner with
a solid serving of carbs so something
like potatoes sweet potatoes corn or a
non-wheat grain if she doesn't do wheat
and also focus on adding in a few
balanced snacks in between those meals
so this would definitely help with
post-workout recovery and also ensure
that she's eating enough calories carbs
and protein to meet her needs now when i
went through a recipe repertoire looking
for some other options that were maybe
higher in protein specifically i
actually found that most of her snacks
only offered between 3 to 10 grams which
is not a lot so since pam has so many
dietary restrictions being pretty much
fully plant-based with no wheat or soy
it definitely whittles down our options
for quality protein so she insisted on
maintaining some of these additional
restrictions
i would probably recommend a non-soy
plant-based protein powder as a
post-workout snack okay now i do want to
focus my critique here on pamela's
attitude towards food and her body
because that's where most of your
comments came in about so first of all
i think it's telling that her family has
apparently nicknamed her the ingredient
police i don't know but if you ask me
considering there is a whole chapter in
the intuitive eating book on how to
reject the food police i can't say that
this is compatible with pamela's
assertion that she is eating intuitively
now second i want to revisit the
moralizing language pana signs to food
so pam often talks about the naturalness
or clean quality of her ingredients she
also suggests cleaning out any processed
or convenient foods in the house that
don't meet her clean all natural food
standards i personally don't think that
this is a sustainable option for most
people and it just makes healthy eating
more elitist and inaccessible i always
say that if a convenience item helps you
get a relatively balanced family meal on
the table then this is a great healthy
tool to lean on in other words if
store-bought dressing means your kids
eat their greens bust out that bottled
ranch i like to think about how these
little kitchen helpers can actually help
to boost the nutrient quality of our
diet overall
by making naturally nourishing foods
more enjoyable and leaning on these
tools are particularly important for
feeding kids but also for adults as well
now i also notice that pamela makes a
bunch of contradictory statements like
not everyone feels guilty after having a
burger you shouldn't anyway as well as
you can eat sweets once in a while
but then juxtaposes that against calling
black forest cake something that
definitely hits your hips and saying
cravings don't come from too few
calories we definitely eat enough of
those
um as we establish lady not everyone is
eating enough of those she also feels
very strongly about calling sugar empty
calories and saying you won't get abs
from sugar again that is factually wrong
ask an athlete if they eat simple
carbohydrates and they will absolutely
tell you
yes yes they do sugar is our body's
preferred energy source and is often
used in competitive and aesthetic sports
to help drive protein into the muscle
fast sugar is also just a simple form of
carbohydrate it's literally just a
macronutrient why do we need to demonize
that not to mention it makes zero sense
to me to make a huge fuss over white
sugar but then just use a ton of maple
syrup and coconut flour sugar in its
place no no he's got a point well
anyways aside from the moralizing
language around food i also uncovered a
lot of pseudoscience easter eggs just
hidden in that little blog of hers that
desperately need to be debunked for
example pam suggests that himalayan salt
does not cause water retention and
regular table salt cannot be properly
absorbed by the body so
the truth is that while himalayan salt
has slightly less sodium for equal
weight
research shows that both table salt and
himalayan sea salt help participants
reach their sodium recommendation in
other words they both contain plenty of
salt enough to cause retention if
consumed in excess and while yes pink
salt does contain more minerals than
refined table salt you would have to
consume a
ton to get any kind of meaningful amount
please please please do not try to meet
your calcium needs through added salt
pam
is also a fan of the food combining diet
which you know i have already discussed
ad nauseam but for some reason this
blood just refuses to die
so this grossly misinformed diet
supposes for example that you need to
eat fruit before other foods and also to
eat it on an empty stomach to prevent a
traffic jam that inhibits normal
digestion
folks this is not true our digestive
system is much more advanced than pamela
is suggesting it is expertly designed to
send out an ideal mix of enzymes to
digest whatever food or mix of foods
find their way into our gut we don't
have to like time it out or combine them
in any specific way the only food
combinations that are evidence-based are
things like adding protein fat or fiber
to your meal to opposition factor and
reduce the blood sugar response or
things like combining vitamin c and iron
to improve absorption but these food
combining rules are total bs next okay
another bogus food rule that she
promotes is not to drink water a half an
hour before a meal during a meal or
upwards of an hour following a meal and
as someone who eats three meals and at
least one snack a day though i would
love to see that bumped up there isn't a
lot of time left for hydration so many
people struggle to maintain their
hydration status so this just really
adds an extra unnecessary obstacle for
people to get their fix so since she's
clearly so concerned with digestion and
bloating she should probably know that
dehydration is probably one of the most
sure-fire ways to back yourself up and
while it's often suggested that drinking
water at meals waters down your
digestive enzymes the evidence that we
have has really proven this to be false
even if it did have an effect our body
would compensate by just making more
enzymes it's really truly amazing
how intuitive our body really is and i
also want to discuss the suggestion of
her naturopathic doctor who told pamela
that a cold drink is comparable to
pouring cold water on a grill so you
need to heat up the grill all over again
before it will work properly um
no your body actually has a pretty
powerful internal temperature regulation
system if it didn't pam would die from
eating like a bowl of her udon miso soup
or from one of her frozen yogurt slices
so no you don't have to drink all your
fluids warm and finally very briefly
pam also seems to subscribe to the
thoroughly debunked alkaline diet oh
lord
give me strength so pamela regularly
shares her belief that acidic foods like
animal products wheat sugar and milk
create an acidic environment that
ultimately puts us at risk for disease
in reality the body actually runs a
pretty tight ship to maintain its proper
ph balance if it didn't we would
literally die from eating a piece of
citrus fruit i know this is totally
morbid but there would be a lot of dead
wellness influencers out there with all
the lemon water that they're drinking
lemon water so
if this is the true reason behind her
diet restrictions then it's definitely
something i would urge her to rethink
because she's missing out on a lot of
eating experiences and nutrition due to
just total bs now what bothers me the
most is not the misinformation found on
pamela's website and her social
properties which let's be real there's a
lot of but it's because they're peppered
throughout all these supportive food
freedom messages which makes it really
difficult for the layperson to determine
if pam is supportive of their food
journeys or not so for example sorting
through her blog posts i see mentions
about mindful eating tips intuitive
eating and supporting local whenever you
can she also discusses a lot of more
nutrition science topics like the
glycemic index and free radicals so it's
easy to see these kind of buzzy food
words and assume that she's an authority
on the topic of nutrition and health but
it's important to note that pamela is
not an expert in nutrition she's not a
dietitian she's not a doctor she's a
beautiful girl with beautifully styled
recipes and i don't know they probably
taste really amazing too and i've also
heard that her workouts are banging so
i'm gonna give her that as well but in
my eyes she should be seen as a food
blogger and a fitness influencer not
someone who should be trusted to be
telling them
what they should or how they should be
eating so i want to bring it back to the
app because i want to summarize some of
my personal thoughts at the handy dandy
pros and cons list to help you decide if
this app is worth a buy so the pros are
that the app is pretty affordable in the
grand scheme of apps it has a nice
variety of nutritious recipes with
adaptable portion sizes and it offers
the convenience of a shopping list which
i love there are also options for people
with different dietary restrictions and
you have the choice to view or ignore
the nutrition facts i also like that
there's a lot of information about
eating more sustainably and cons is that
a lot of pam's nutrition content is not
evidence-based and could potentially
lead to disorderly eating behaviors or
investing in unnecessary
inaccessible products i also find that a
lot of the language related to food is
quite moralizing dichotomizing and
ultimately not compatible with the
intuitive eating messages that she seems
to be pushing as of late with all this
considered if you're looking for a
convenient hub to plan healthy meals and
workouts
this app might be a good investment for
you however i want to make sure everyone
is aware that the information provided
is not coming from a nutrition
professional and as a result contains a
good amount of nutrition lies and food
fear mongering and folks that is all
that i have for you guys today i hope
this video was useful in helping you
make a more informed decision about
whether or not to purchase the pam app
so if you liked it be sure to give it
the thumbs up
leave me a comment below if you like
this video and what you would like to
see me review next subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen
bye